ya vimos que el atp es energía para las
moléculas pero en este vídeo me gustaría
que nos adentremos un poco más como
vimos anteriormente cuando pasamos de
atp
a dp más un grupo fosfato se libera
energía y si analizamos el sistema aquí
está la energía que se libera del atp
pero una vez que ocurre la hidrólisis y
se forma a bp más un grupo fosfato la
energía libre cae aproximadamente 30.5
kilo jules por mol del traje es igual a
menos 30 puntos 5 kilos por mol y como
vimos en los vídeos sobre la energía
libre de jeeps esto nos dice que la
reacción es espontánea cuando delta g es
menor a 0 eso significa que la reacción
es espontánea
si esto es espontáneo porque no todo el
atp y toda el agua se convierten en adp
espontáneamente y liberan energía en
forma de calor o algo parecido bueno eso
es porque primero hay que superar esta
energía miren aquí tenemos una energía
de activación que si no tenemos una
enzima como catalizador aumenta un poco
y esto es porque cuando el atp se rompe
bueno si habláramos de la hidrólisis de
la molécula de agua que es con lo que
generalmente relacionamos la hidrólisis
aunque puede ocurrir con otras moléculas
si pensamos en la molécula de agua
necesitamos que este par de electrones
libres en el oxígeno puedan hacer algo
llamado ataque nucleo físico en este
grupo fosfato y si eso ocurre se formará
un enlace con lo que estos electrones se
moverán de regreso a este oxígeno lo que
le da al oxígeno una carga negativa y
tal vez me diga ok
esto tiene sentido pero recuerden los
electrones son negativos y están
rodeados por estas cargas negativas así
que estos electrones tendrán que
sobrepasar el hecho de estar cerca de
estas cargas porque conforme se acercan
las cargas negativas se repelen entre sí
y eso es lo que tienen que superar
entonces una forma de superarlas es con
la ayuda de una clase de enzimas
conocidas como atp asas
atp asas estas enzimas son proteínas
complejas muy grandes en las que la
molécula de atp se puede combinar muy
bien y lo que hacen estas enzimas es
tratar de rodear la molécula de atp con
algunos iones positivos supongamos que
aquí tenemos un ión positivo así podemos
mantener a estos electrones ocupados
mientras que aquí se da el ataque núcleo
físico sin tener que preocuparnos por
estos electrones y supongamos que
también tenemos unión positivo aquí ok y
bueno recuerden que si pensamos en tres
dimensiones esto se encuentra en todas
las direcciones envolviendo a la
molécula de atp
aquí tenemos atp asa
entonces al tener la enzima aquí la
energía de activación disminuye y nos
queda algo como esto la reacción puede
ocurrir y la razón por la que no vemos
que esto ocurra fácilmente sin una
enzima es porque tendríamos que
sobrepasar esto pero una vez que tenemos
enzimas
la energía de activación disminuye
permitiendo que la reacción ocurra
entonces esto ataca aquí formando este
enlace y bueno aquí tenemos otro
hidrógeno
que puede ser tomado por otra molécula
de agua para convertirse en un bio ni
troneo que es lo que ocurre realmente y
bueno después esta parte puede tomar
este par de electrones lo que le da una
carga negativa y entonces de este lado
nos queda un grupo fosfato y de este
lado tenemos el atp y claro hubo una
liberación de energía ahora normalmente
no queremos que se libere energía solo
porque si la mayoría de las atp asas
impulsan esa energía liberada en esta
reacción para fosforila una molécula en
este caso podemos pensar que el grupo
hidróxido fue fosforilada pero se podría
fosforila otra cosa o podría cambiar la
conformación de ésta atp hasta para
hacer otras cosas como transferir
moléculas en contra del gradiente de
concentración o del gradiente
electroquímico lo que sea que ocurra no
queremos simplemente liberar energía
claro puede ocurrir algunas veces si
queremos generar calor pero generalmente
esa energía puede ser utilizada por las
células espero que esto les ayude a
entender un poco más el atp y la
reacción por la que ocurre la hidrólisis
a esto se le conoce como hidrólisis
porque al menos en este ejemplo estamos
usando una molécula de agua para romper
la molécula y separar un grupo fosfato